these dances can make me feel confident
and make me feel sexy and desirable
former bachelorette Hannah brown credits
Dancing with the Stars
for bringing her sexy back but not for
any man she says it's all about
self-love I'm not really focused on my
love life right now at all
so I'm not really thinking about that
when it comes to confidence and feeling
sexy that I think that's more for myself
and to know that I can I am all those
things and when I really truly feel that
way every single day then when it comes
the time to really focus on my love life
or if somebody just comes in my life
unexpectedly then I'll be better than
the four things it's a lot more than
just dancing this whole journey and I've
definitely learned that it's really
about the journey of self exploration
and discovery in becoming a more full
whole woman et caught up with Hannah
just days before her dancing debut where
she revealed how she's prepping for
Monday night's big premiere I'm feeling
really good I've been working really
hard so I'm excited to see what it's
actually like to perform and get all
that nervous energy out and then just
feel comfortable that's possible for me
it's all mental stuff like I am
I'm picking up the steps I feel like
okay like getting them not easily but
getting them but it's really eyes
standing in my way sometimes of really
performing and I think that is going to
be part of my journey this whole
experience is really just allowing
myself to breathe and in dance freely
and be confident in this new picture my
feet are destroyed but they are
disgusting they stink so bad out of my
shoes on my foot and they look really
terrible and my back hurts pretty bad
just because I like I'm not used to
holding myself up this way and doing
these dips and these leg lifts and stuff
so yeah my whole body hurts really bad
but you know what it's all worth it
maybe I hope I don't look at everyone as
competition like this whole thing is a
competition against myself because I am
my toughest critic and I'm going to be
my toughest competition because I'm the
one that stands in the way of me
performing my very best I think it's
really important that we lift each other
up then also be able to like show each
other our dances and and talk about how
this is really grueling but also really
fun I'm excited for this new stage you
want to start singing although we'll
have to wait to find out who Hannah's
partner is she did give us a few hints
he's Russian he's really fun and
also really tough on me but I feel like
that's everyone she also teased to her
first dance it's going to be something
that everybody's gonna want to get up
and dance with me too
it's a really classic song and it's
really fast and really tough actually I
think it's a really challenging first
night dance but I've been working really
really hard on it and trying to work on
my technique and it's gonna be something
that everybody's gonna really enjoy when
it comes to potentially winning the
mirror ball
Hannah beast tell ZT it's all about the
journey I think about it sometimes a
year ago I was still living in Alabama
just did not thought did not ever think
my life would be this that I'm
considered a star on Dancing with the
Stars like a year ago that would have
never been anything in my wildest dreams
and I think for me this has just been a
constant journey of this new life and
taking ownership of it and is it
anything like I expected even two months
ago no but really just celebrating where
I am and the opportunities that I have
and ain't growing in my confidence that
there's so much to be joyful about
doing master's dance and also being okay
with the times where I am struggling and
being vulnerable and open with that
because I think that's why the people
who have supported me support me because
I'm just an I am just a normal girl that
has been kind of thrust into this life
and continuing to own that and be an
example